I want to talk about something that
[ __ ] me up last night last night with
headphones on this one and this is
serious okay I want you to weigh in
weight but let me tell you what I'm
about to tell you okay so my brother and
I went to armed do pars last night to
get some pancakes which one want a
valley
no the one on Third Street the one in
the grove oh there oh yeah okay you know
yeah we have great pancakes yeah yeah so
my brother and I we order a gigantic
cinnamon roll mmm the heated butter on
it
we're eating it it's delicious right my
brother goes hey man what's going on
nothing
so tag it belly this and that yeah
what's that no Trump
so we can talk about Trump a little bit
yeah and I go you know it's so funny
Jordan Peele came to tiger bail and he
said doesn't it feel like we're living
in an alternate reality Jordan said that
on the thing remember and my brother
goes oh you're talking about the Mandela
effect
oh yeah have you heard of it big time
yeah what is it
bear steam baby yeah yeah yeah so what
it is is this okay big this is what my
brother's explained to me that yeah
drink it there was a point in time we
don't know when probably 10 15 20 years
ago they were a shift in we're living
now in an alternate reality and in the
shift things have changed so the things
that we remember aren't the same anymore
right and so we started googling
examples of it right and literally it
blew my [ __ ] mind dude you just heard
about this I just heard about it bro I
love this I go down this rabbit hole
yeah yeah but I'll let you talk let me
tell you guys some examples right yeah
and then like for instance Forrest Gump
yeah right okay what ask you Gilbert
what does he say about chocolates life
is like a box of chocolate what is it
life is like a box of chocolates yes no
Jernigan yeah that's not what he says
okay mom you know what says he says you
say it one more time so it's like their
life is like a box of chocolates it's
out there LA
that lack a baja do you remember that do
you remember that yes that is not what
he says he says life was like a box of
chocolate do you remember there was no
exactly so that's the example right we
heard it as is but if you look it on
YouTube and look at that scene it was
can I just do that
yeah go ahead really quickly yeah you're
looking at the way your reality is just
a hallucination of a filter of all the
knowledge that you've accumulated your
whole life because of the second
sentence that he says you never know
what you're gonna get the automatic
assumption is he did say life is a box
of chocolates if he didn't say life is a
box of chocolates and then it's great
the second sentence is grammatically
wrong do you understand yeah so you're
going to assume that he said life is
like a box of chocolates because that's
the only way that those two sentences
actually grammatically makes sense or
there was a shift your hands away from
what I'm saying is like you know like
dangling participles and all that right
now no using the forks like you know and
you don't in a sentence on go ahead Oh
give me another example your sentence
was grammatically incorrect well if
you're saying life was like a box of
chocolates you never know what you're
going to get those two sentences
together don't actually quite make quite
as much sense as life is like a box of
chocolates you never know what you're
going to get awful I was like no you
never know yeah I did say no no I knew
yeah he didn't yeah you never if he had
said you never knew what you were gonna
get then the was would have made
and now can ID bunk your debunk yeah
yeah yeah cuz I'm already deep in this
rabbit hole yeah yeah in fact all I just
want you to okay there's a video box and
it says on it life was like they have
evidence no I'm sure that's exactly what
he said what I'm saying is how we heard
it is know what I'm saying is what we
believe he said was unrecorded history
on a video box oh do you understand yeah
it still was his oh you understand yeah
there was a quote you can find it there
was one that says life was like wow
there's a lot of these I'll give you
another example Froot Loops yeah how do
you spell it
I can debunk that okay FRU i TL PS nope
you know what the reality is no what
what I actually thought it was fruit
but-- no no is it you know oh oh oh
fruit is spelled f ro ot Loops
I thought that was spelt like that no
okay
when I was a kid I would look at the
Froot Loops box and go that's Froot
Loops
uit okay another reason yeah if you're
in the fifth grade and you're told to
spell fruit your entire life as fr uit
when you look at something you're not
looking at individual letters you're
looking at the general message so when
you're looking at it quickly you're not
dissecting the oh oh you're gonna
automatically revert back to fifth grade
you know grammar and spelling and you're
gonna say it's F ruit and you're gonna
Emblaze that into your memory so that's
how that works what you well your
reality is just a hallucination of all
the knowledge you've accumulated in your
life
there was a shift alright here's another
another one
the bernstein bear what's the Bernstein
yeah I didn't I've never heard of the
Bernstein birthday what are you Joe my
age dude I never heard of him
I don't bear I had different ways always
so that example never just didn't like
you bring alright like okay so the
monopoly guy yeah
that's not that weird of one but yes I
do like that one okay what does he have
a monocle or not yes yes he doesn't
never had one never had a mom how old
are you 28 exactly I'm 7 years older
than you and I thought the same as I
think so that means it's not just our
generation yeah tweet to your tweet too
so yeah there's a lot more okay dude do
the Curious George and I'll debunk that
what curious no I'll do the Curious
George so I can debunk it this is
Curious George you were hell-bent on
this no don't look it up Shirley I'm so
shocked by later do it later alright a
better one but go ahead no I don't want
to do that one I want to do another one
yeah Snow White
okay when they when the evil was a tweet
Maleficent well when she looks in the
mirror what did she say he says mirror
mirror on the wall what did you say
mirror mirror on the wall right stop
like this that's not what she says what
is it magic mirror on the wall howdy
bunk that one oh I thought was beer
mirror oh I'll tell you why it was she
trying to tell me about I reckon I have
a [ __ ] argument with that the right
is damn yeah
not on this because it's got this as a
gift right on that yeah Keep Calm the
bunka the bunka yeah in the original
Brothers Grimm story it is Mirror Mirror
and Walt Disney took liberties in the
movie to change it to magic mirror if
you were if you were a child reading
original Brothers Grimm stories it was
Mirror Mirror and so they're
interchangeable they have always been
that way
here's the thing though that argument
okay I never read about the Brothers
Grimm I did I never did I don't even
know who they are all I know is I saw
Snow White okay I know that I seen that
scene in the cartoon the Disney version
where she looks in the mirror and she
says mirror mirror on the wall but she
never says that she says magic mirror so
that argument right there if I knew
about the Brothers Grimm then that'd be
one thing but I don't know anything
about that you know I always thought
that did I honestly thought that Snow
White was a Disney concoction can I just
say that there's a science to collective
miss misremembering yeah I was gonna
rotate down so I want to hear your
opinion on that I gotta tell you
something okay collective misremembering
it's like all we need to do it all you
need to tell me one time is Mirror
Mirror and I say yeah that's how it is
and I'm gonna put that in my memory and
that's how I'm going to disseminate all
my information for the rest of my life
and I'll never write because I don't
know any better I'm not going to argue
with you and tell you wait isn't it this
it's Mirror Mirror right right that's
how I learned it growing up that's what
I was told am I gonna argue with my
third grade teacher and say hey that's
actually in the movie it said magic
mirror and that's how things are
perpetuated and that's how
misremembering continues collect a
misremembering there is an explanation
an actual logical explanation to this
you're just trying to like you know you
want it to be a shift but it's not
the shift science aware pillar
Philippines this is incredible because
you're saying the stuff that I've read
yeah you're so [ __ ] smart let me take
this yeah dude
so I don't know exactly the science
behind it
but I read some of it but she said she
said they got like scientists to go on
and there's a reason why we all it's
kind of like the hundredth monkey
principle we're all connected and
there's like a hundred monkeys do
something and they somehow have the
energy on to tell the monkey a thousand
miles away I can't explain it all but
something like that but did you know why
they say this is happening why she's so
practical weather which ice so is it
like you're of a practical brain and you
I don't know if your science background
and like bobbi and myself have like a
gullible brain I don't want to look at
things and believe that I think that
that's also a way to escape one's
reality or your own pain I could say
that I don't know what the pain would be
a moon bring the bear bear seem bigger
but so ok I want to ask you but so do
you know what they say the shift is no
so did Jordan tell you or no no ok he
just set up broadly ok here's what the
shift oh now I'm we're about to not
sleep tonight after dude I love this
[ __ ] and this is I do believe there's a
collective woken as' you know how people
say they're getting woke but I think
there's a lot of [ __ ] you know yeah
you know let's keep it a hundred just
[ __ ] no one keeps it a hundred oh I
keep it like 72 long time picture barely
passing sorry there's five right there
but um they say that this happened with
CERN you know what CERN no sir no that
that underground atom cylinder so what
they say is happening is is that they're
trying to recreate the Big Bang but it's
dangerous because it's basically all the
powers that be to smash
Adam I don't know exactly it's just what
they're trying to do is like infinity
war type yeah and if you do that it's
for every action there's an opposite
equal yeah reaction so there they did it
underground that's miles long they claim
they haven't got it yet but they're
saying by trying that yeah this is gonna
sound crazy and I'm trying to put my
brain around I already believe it that's
somehow yeah yeah we have shifted you
don't want to say because there are 11
dimensions that we know about so the
there's the basic up down and over
that's three yeah the fourth one is
where you can tie two together so for
instance to get from this state on how
do I explain it if if Japan's above us
yeah instead of going the way you can
normally do that you there's a wormhole
and you can get to a quicker
that's the fort that's just a fourth
dimension Wow they say that we Teeter
back and forth and that's why weird
shits happening a couple of conspiracy
theories which I hate being called that
yeah yeah cuz it's like why can't be
altered so can you debunk that it
doesn't that sound interested that
sounds interesting to me I love it we're
going to CERN okay buy the tickets I
actually don't think that that's
necessarily conspiracy theorists
thinking I think that that's something
to me that's more tangible because I
need that that sounds like physics to me
yes and I am NOT somebody just because
I'm more science minded I do believe
they're like we watch a lot of
time-travel stuff love it and I'm really
hardcore into that stuff yeah I just
think that when it comes to I think that
the human mind is heavily unreliable I
think that what we see what we think we
see is very inaccurate maybe a
combination of two things I don't
I trust the elemental things around us I
don't trust the human mind who spills
fruit to old a company that wants to
attract kids like he was tripping out on
Looney Tunes spelled tu and yet me too
okay I'll give you a proper explanation
to that in my mind the reason that you
see it as T ough ons because
cartoons and of course when you're
thinking and you're watching cartoons
automatically you're gonna read Looney
Tunes forward about this one really
early tea that was always et no no it
was Dustin Hoffman he says this what is
he saying
alright phone home et phone home yeah he
doesn't say that now this one I didn't
hear yeah he says et home phone no yeah
yeah debunk that debunking Devi but the
reason why we think that he says phone
home is because one of the other getting
to Barrymore says et phone home and so
in our heads that sounds you know me
that's what's that
let's talk Dustin Hoffman says et home
phone okay JCPenney oh that's a that's
another good one how do you spell it
yeah okay stop stop what yeah okay and
hey she already know that I am sorry
left shoulder last night and I debunked
this yeah yeah yeah how do you it's JC
PE and and II why who smells penny with
an e yeah no one I attend the country's
you are there's a controversy is not the
way it's spelled it's the way we see it
we see it as completely and many why but
of course we would see it that way
because that's how penny is spelled yeah
what I'm saying is you're going to see
things the way we know with Kanye is
white Kanye is why dimensional we're
seeing it wrong
I really I'm gonna have you I'm gonna
send you this TED talk about your
reality being just a hallucination and
yeah it is one of the most interesting
things I've ever think it seems like an
eel set I've heard these but I haven't
heard and it's true yeah but everything
you're saying makes complete sense yeah
and that's why witnesses to like with
crimes and all those things they're
really unreliable because what you see
is really you're looking through a
filter of your own implicit biases of
people of events of all the knowledge
that you've accumulated all of your
[ __ ] yeah you're singing on a clean
slate so so let me ask you this
I read something recently so many of
this stuff I love that we're talking
about this would you know when you go
I'll say to you the bathroom yeah go
peepee yeah no like you know when you go
to Schaumburg yes for the first time
yeah and you're like oh my god at the
mall and I'm gonna go down to the city
yeah go to the Cubby Bear and have a
drink I don't know anything but whatever
and you go to Chicago and and it's like
and after about six times you're like
I'm gonna go to my room I'm gonna sleep
I'm gonna get Starbucks I'm gonna do my
shows okay you're not gonna do anything
anymore that's exactly what yes and I'm
like what I was going on like why don't
I attack the city anymore and I read
something that when the reason why
things are so exciting when we're young
is because our brain is informed and so
when we see something for the first time
going to Tampa Florida is like going to
Mars and I literally just did shows like
in Beirut and it was awesome but like I
kind of understood the experience cuz
I've been all over the world yeah and I
was just fine chillin having a shawarma
so yeah I guess what I'm asking you
scientists is that they say that our
brain yeah once we hit a certain age
once we do something the luster of it
goes away that's where we get Lube I
[ __ ] mind just look we get bored it's
so it's almost like why you keep walking
you get tired yeah
well it's the same reason you can you
can draw a parallel with with kids not
wanting to like eat a lot of exciting
foods and kids have a very basic palette
and the reason is their taste buds are
being introduced for the very first time
to these certain foods and it's oh it's
an over excitement of their taste buds
right but the reason that adults like us
have a wider range of things that we can
eat is because we've actually
desensitized like we can't taste things
as well as children and so we kind of
the flavors aren't as like strong or
exciting and we can eat a lot bigger of
a variety of things that's how I kind of
see it it's like you know hindered it
was Bobby Orr like it's me Bobby yeah
Wow they blow him away with my society
yeah I was a biochem major but like but
also yeah so she's you know it's great
what cuz I hate it when Miami are you
millennial I don't know
I'm 33 I think I'm a fish but like
you're not millennial but like
Millennials like younger ones when they
tell me something like this you're all
you're explaining it to me in such a way
and I'm gonna hurt it be it's very
logical see you're not making me feel
like I'm a [ __ ] idiot Millennials
would be like and yeah dummy like as
they're like on there's marks yeah yeah
yeah and such like you're like really
inclusive what do you all make sense she
has character defects I do I that she's
hiding from you robot on yes-mo
right mode right other modes 92 other
mode yeah yeah nicholae I'm breaking
down as I'm explaining this to you is
the clicker neat touch my hand don't get
grossed out to show you then yeah yeah
yeah this is a just look at it you don't
have to touch it oh you're sweaty
why because anytime I drink I have this
thing my body sweats broken I wiped it
on myself I didn't get we're gonna get
the knowledge wait is that one of the
defense refute little side treat right
I'm sweaty
[Music]